this is a basketball this is a Spalding
basketball you can buy this at the store
for $20 now this is used to entertain
this is used as a form of exercise but
one guy used this $20 tool to make 2
point 1 billion dollars let me do the
math for you $20 turned into 2 point 1
billion dollars that's 105 million times
return on investment okay and that man's
name is Michael Jordan the last five
weeks every Sunday millions of people
around the world have tuned in to the
last dance today I'm going to share with
you 23 lessons I learned from the last
days here cash the ball by the way for
full disclosure Spalding hat the NBA
account for 30 years that they just lost
to Wilson so Spalding that's a big
account to lose because everybody bought
this ball Wilson
congratulations to having said that
let's get right into it point number one
that I took away if you're a LeBron
James fan or if the argument of who's
the greatest of all time if there was
ever a time that was the worst time for
any anti MJ fans I'm talking to LeBron
any other type of player fans if there
was ever a time that you didn't want the
last dance to come out it was this time
let me explain to you what it was almost
as if it was perfect you got a pandemic
happens everybody's forced to stay home
there's no sports no football no
basketball no MLB the only sport
conversation is the last dance and it
lasts for five weeks all the LeBron
James fans were sitting there watching
LeBron fan now cuz he's a Laker himself
I'm a Laker fan right if you don't think
MJ's the goat you're either delusional
you're a troll you're in your 20s or
you're a teenager or your team lost to
him or number five you simply didn't
watch the last sense because lesson
number one is Michael is the greatest of
all time no one comes close to him his
DNA
killer instinct what he did I was doing
the math the other day if you look at
the Pistons games they lost they should
have beaten Pistons in one of the series
which they would have gone to the finals
and
the game number seven that Pippin didn't
come well he was having anxiety tech
panic attacks if people place to his
best they when they go to Championships
that's two additional championship if
Mike doesn't retire those two additional
ones they would have beaten the Rockets
that two other right there and if they
would have come back one more season
that would have been 11 championships he
would have probably had 43,000 career
points if he wouldn't have had any any
of those things taking place then play a
couple more season forty-three thousand
points 42,000 points all times score all
time everything that's Michael
so my point number one is the argument
for who's the greatest of all time in
the history of NBA the game of MBA it's
over with at least for 20 more years the
arguments over with that's my point
number one point number two just as much
as the argument was made that he's the
greatest of all time Michael Jordan
here's the challenge why that's not
gonna last for a long time
why do you say that Pat here's why
forget about all the players that watch
the last night's oh my gosh all the
tweets did you see Mike my favorite
episodes number seven oh did you see one
hour or another forget about all the
players that are playing today forget
about them because the level of
improvement in their game cannot be
dramatic here's what's scary about it
millions millions of young kids eight
year old kid twelve year old kid 11 year
old kid watched the last dance these
kids got got a clinic on what it is to
have a killer instinct for free they
just watch these episodes on ESPN there
are gonna be thousands of kids that are
out outside in the backyard shooting
basket with their mom screaming it's
late it's dark get inside no mom 20 more
shots get inside right now 20 more shots
mom get inside thousands those are the
kids I'm excited about the NBA is gonna
be so excited 13 14 15 years from now oh
my gosh I can't wait to see what the NBA
is gonna look like there you think Mike
Michael never had a last dance to watch
let me say this one more time Michael
never had a last dance to watch take the
last dance
give it to a Michael who was a young kid
imaginable Michael would have been today
the odds are the game the sport of an
MBA that the brand the MBA it just got
better 15 years from now just can't wait
for 2035 NBA draft pick I can't wait for
that I can't wait for that day because
it's gonna be crazy number three my
favorite quote of all time is if a line
could speak we could not understand them
if there is a quote to describe Michael
the best it's this quote why everybody
wants to criticize Michael oh he was a
bully oh he was an [ __ ] oh he was a
jerk that's not the way did you see the
words to use did you see what he said to
the Parral did you see how he punked
iske did you see what he did to cur
oh my gosh I can't believe what a bully
he is you know we're talking about here
with Mario and Kaiba if he was a bully
Maury Mario said he was a bully guy said
I don't think he was a bully they were
both right by the time it was over with
of course he's a bully Kai's point was
he was not a bully because he didn't
bully to belittle you without any
outcome he bullied you to get the best
out of you because if you could handle
him you could handle anybody the part
when he fights Steve Kerr and Kerr
punches him in the chest after he fouled
him hard and then he punches him in the
face in the eye right there he told Phil
you keep calling these ticky-tack fouls
when I'm fouling them what are you gonna
do when this guy faces off in the mix
how is he gonna handle it that's Michael
Michael is a lion and if you don't
understand him you are not a lion point
umber for every great organization has
an [ __ ] in it
now this [ __ ] here was Jerry Krause
hate it you know just a made fun of
hey don't smoke cigars because it could
stunt your growth hey you know no matter
what no wonder you're so sure all it is
Scottie everybody that bully Jerry did
you see how the end took place when Phil
got up and they knew was the last dance
and still gave respect to the gym and
even Scottie Pippen who
lead him said the following he says can
you imagine what it was like to be part
of the greatest organization
Scottie's words to play with the
greatest player of all time the greatest
coach of all time and you know what else
he said the greatest general manager of
all time the guy he hated the most
he brought tax fail God read a call ins
Rodman Horace replaced packs and brought
cur are you kidding me
every great organization has an [ __ ]
like Jerry Krause who's a great
recruiter point number five MJ had a
long fu list and by the way he always
found ways to add new names to the list
George Karl you come to the restaurant
I'm eating you see me you walk out you
don't say bye to me
no problem I see Thomas we play against
you two years in a row
you Punk us in the playoffs you kick us
out I still come and shake your hand we
beat you the next year the lambier tells
you don't shake hands and you walk out
no problem when it comes on to the dream
team the Bradford Smith 37 points hey
good game like whether he said it or not
no problem Media Chicago media they're
gonna go to Cleveland they're not gonna
win no problem Magic Bird it doesn't
matter this man constantly added names
to his list and it's Roman sometimes you
may want to create your own fu list and
help it drive you point number six don't
chase money too early let me say this
one more time don't chase money too
early Michael was never the highest-paid
guy in the NBA until his last year with
the Bulls when he got paid thirty three
million dollars never you know what
Michael chased michael chased greatness
when he chased greatness everything came
to him endorsements money opportunity
movies everything because he chased
greatness more than he chased money you
chase greatness guaranteed money is
coming early you over negotiate your
value in the marketplace prior to
earning greatness your short-term
thinker 0.7 cap
some works when MJ first got in the
league and he was getting a shoe deal
converse was number one they had magic
dad Bert when his team went to converse
they said we can't make him the face
why because we have magic and Bertie
haven't earned the right yet he liked
adidas adidas didn't have the money to
paint a quarter million dollar check
Falk goes to New Moon Nike Michael
wasn't a Nike fan mom and dad call and
say go meet with Nike and just listen to
them he goes meets with them the company
that wasn't first wasn't second it was
third on the list when and competed for
Mike as a talent they got him what
happened to Mike greatest of all time
what happened to Nike the best sporting
shoe brand athletic brand in the world
capitalism works point number eight
leadership matters and you have to know
who's gonna get the best out of your
people when Michael was playing for Doug
Collins
there was a scene when Michael was
playing and duck they asked him in the
interview so Doug what play did you call
when you were for Michael and timeout he
said I just told everybody get the ball
to Michael and get the hell out of his
way now obviously he dropped the f-bomb
but he says get out of his way and oh
haha so funny hilarious no problem
Jerry Krauss's realizes you're gonna win
a championship run it about the one
person he brings a guy named Tex winner
texter winner brings us triangle offense
he brings it to the team Doug Collins
and tech start having fights together to
the point where Doug doesn't even let
him sit on the bench he tells the guy
you don't need to be here then Jerry
goes gets Phil who was a coach in Puerto
Rico who was coaching a whole different
league in Albany New York tough guy
former New York player who won a couple
championships in 1972 I believe he
brings him on board as the assistant the
assistant starts having more credibility
than Doug they decided to get rid of
Doug Jerry notice Doug cannot get the
best out of the team
they bring filling Phil comes in Phil
says Mike the balls not going through
you every single time mike says what are
you talking about Mike loved Doug at
that time because the ball always went
through him Phil said it's not going to
go through you
you can be the greatest scorer of all
time and never won a championship or you
can be maybe top two top three score and
win championships which one do you want
Mike bought in to the stronger leader
Phil Jackson Phil came in Phil got the
best out of Mike Mike trusted game over
sometimes a better leader is gonna get
better at you it's gonna get more out of
your people point over not if you decide
to be big in your industry whatever
you're doing I want to be one of the
best of all time I want to be big I want
to be million I want to be a billionaire
no problem in the road of going and
becoming a million or being successful
being the best in your industry you're
gonna get the attention of the media
media loves stories like that you know
why because media looks at the great
American success story they say yeah
there's got to be something maybe this
person is an alcoholic maybe he's a
druggie maybe he's a cocaine maybe he's
a womanizer maybe it's a gambler maybe
he's got some family it's just maybe
he's maybe he's a narcissistic but maybe
they're gonna come after you and you can
either go head-on with media or you can
build a relationship with them Mike
chose to develop a relationship with the
media and he managed expectation and it
ended up actually being a great
relationship with the media loved him
and he loved the media part number 10
there's a scene of one of the episodes
where Reggie Miller from the Pacers is
talking about what it was like to shoot
space gem and they built a basketball
court for him and Michael brought all
the players and summertime everybody was
playing against each other and he said
he would come he would play with us for
three hours after three hours he would
go work out after work out here
then he would do this then he had a six
o'clock then he said discount was a
vampire when did he ever sleep by the
way so many stories Michael play poker
all night Michael did this all night
Michael for a person like Michael to do
what they do they have a certain level
of energy that's indescribable
they don't need coffee they don't need
all the other stuff their determination
is so flippin big and laser beam focused
to make their vision a reality where
they typically can go with less sleep
than others do and some may call them
vampire part number 11 your one new
teammate one new employee one new player
one new client one new salesperson one
person away from taking your company to
hold it from Louisville from taking your
team to whole different level one player
changed a franchise from four thousand
people coming to the game to sell out
since the day Michael got drafted the
Bulls have been a sellout one guy comes
to the city of Chicago changes the game
economically Fame party and nightlife
restaurants in every possible way find
that one person changed the life of your
business forever to come pour number 12
there's a scene where he is doing the
commercial with Spike Lee and Spike Lee
says it's gotta be the shoes no it's not
the shoes it's gotta be this no it's not
it's got and find him I said look here's
what I was trying to say it's not the
shoes it's not it's my work if he says I
guarantee if I average two points a game
nobody would have pay me the kind of
money they paid me nobody would have
come to watch me Mike said this Mike
said this by the way you know the big
baller brand great idea but xot didn't
show up if zou was Mike let's take that
same idea big baller brand and let's
make zou MJ
big baller brand but it's MJ who is big
baller brand you know what would happen
happened the big baller brand it
probably would have been a multi-billion
dollar empire because it's the player
you bank on you might have a great idea
it's the player you bank on Mike said I
work so hard to get good at my craft it
ain't the shoes it's my work ethic and
my game that got me to where I'm at
today
point number thirteen eventually for an
empire for a company for an organization
to flourish there's got to be trust you
have to trust the coach Mike finally
trust it Phil and Mike learned the hard
way he didn't trust any of his teammates
he learned to trust Pippen he learned to
trust BJ Armstrong he learned to trust
Paxson he learned to trust Kukoc he
learned to trust Iker and eventually you
want six championship but women get the
highest level Trust is very critical
point number fourteen sometimes to bring
back a client to bring back a recruit to
bring back a talent to bring back
somebody that maybe
kept away or stepped away for a couple
years or is retired or there was a
falling out sometimes the person to do
that isn't the number one person in the
company or number two or number three or
number four or anything it's just
somebody that the other guy had a
relationship with and in this case BJ
Armstrong had a relationship with
Michael and so when Michael was in
Chicago and BJ said hey man let's play I
don't think you can beat me one on one
day play Michael trusted BJ BJ
encouraged him to come back
BJ indirectly recruited Michael back
just because Michael trusted BJ because
BJ was harmless and the rest is history
point number 15 sometimes when you win
at something and I mean at the highest
highest level everybody tells you how
amazing you are you start believing you
can be amazing at everything you do and
it's just not true
and it's very very hard for hyper
competitive people very Michael goes
does the basketball thing becomes the
greatest ghost plays baseball then
leaves and I know some people said if
you had 1500 more at-bats he would ended
up being a baseball player proffession
all this but he would have never been
the greatest baseball player of all time
oh they became the blade greatest
basketball player of all time know your
limits and be comfortable with what you
can and cannot do I understand if he did
the baseball thing to get it out of his
system fully get it fully understand why
that decision was made father all that
stuff fully get that part but you won't
be great at everything just please just
because you were great at one thing
point over 16 there's a scene where
they're sitting there since well that's
what they did to Shaq and you know
that's what's going on with Shaq and you
know here's what this is on that Shaq
and they said again says I'm not Shaq
they said again says I'm not Shaq now
what was he saying you're a lot of
different ways you can interpret that
guy's at that level hate to be compared
I mean hate to be compared to anybody
don't compare me to anybody I'm one of a
kind do not compare me to anybody
Michael wanted to prove a point that
don't ever compare anyone else to me I'm
one of a kind if you think you're one of
a kind you can say don't compare me to
anybody but every time he was called
compared to somebody else he went
improved everybody wrong that he's one
of a kind if you don't want to be
compared to anybody go make the argument
that parts on you what number 17 look
just because you hate an opponent
doesn't mean you can't respect them you
know when they asked him about Isaiah
you could tell he cannot stand Isaiah as
a person you could tell I mean it was
losing out of him how he can't stand
Isaiah as a person but he said to me he
is the second greatest point card of all
time behind Magic Johnson and that's a
lot of respect because you tell my
Stockton tell about all these modern-day
point guards he put him second greatest
of all time Isaiah Thomas so just
because you don't like an opponent
doesn't mean you can respect their game
point number 18 you see the more you
compete in your field and you beat
people right all you know I'm beating
people at YMCA I'm beating people at
Venice Beach
I mean solar real estate oh I'm beating
people in my own office oh it's great oh
I mean people in my region oh that's
great and then when it gets to
nationally then you face real
competitors okay so you may be the alpha
of your small little office you may be
the alpha of your region but as it gets
bigger you realize who the real alpha is
they're planing the dream team they're
playing that pickup game or magics
talking trash birds on the sidelines
they're going back and forth and magic
may have been a better trash talker even
Gary Payton may have been a better trash
talker a lot of players may have been
better trash talkers but eventually
nobody was a bigger alpha than Michael
Jordan not because he was a bigger alpha
cos there's this misconception that
alpha is about personality alphas not
personality alpha is results in the
field you've chosen to compete in if
you're an alpha that means you beat all
the other alphas and that's exactly what
Michael did once
Michael beat all the other alphas he
didn't have to say nothing magic came
out and says we just realized when Burt
came up and says listen there's a new
sheriff in town magic we just have to
accept it this guy's just better than us
and it was game over
so don't Bank your alpha think on
personality Bank it on your game
don't be afraid of challenging your
people and don't apologize for it you
know one of my favorite personalities in
the history of football was Mike Ditka
I loved it here's a guy that ended up
becoming creating the new position tight
end then he goes and becomes a player
you know wins a championship coaching
wins a championship and then later on in
life when I interviewed him he was
apologetic about how hard he was with
people how much he pushed him it was
almost like well maybe I shouldn't have
done this I'm like I didn't want to see
that it was almost like I wish I would
have never done the interview because I
want to take that out of my mind what I
liked about Mike Ditka and the interview
saying here's a quarter go call someone
who cares and said you know what the way
the guy was it's just if you ever want
to watch highlights on Mike that guy's a
coach go watch him the 84 Bears
documentary Mario we watched that work
we took like 50 people and we watch it
at Oheka castle in new york we rented
out the entire property 32 rooms and I
had everybody watching a documentary why
don't apologize for driving the hell out
of you people but be aware to have a
cushion above you what do I mean by this
if you are the highest level of cushion
and you drive the hell out of everybody
and they can't go somewhere else
you're in trouble meaning let me explain
Michael is driving everybody Borel cur
Pippen Horace
he's driving everybody that if he
crosses the line Phil will say get out
of the game go home what you told him
Phil told them and then Phil calls
Jordan saying call to Curren apologize
then Jordan called Curt pologize because
curse spoke to Phil and it was furious
there's a cushion drive but make sure
you're good with the person above you
because that cushion is needed for you
to be able to drive harder I don't know
if this part makes sense or not in some
environments it may not be possible but
you got to make sure you drive people to
a level with having a cushion that
people say things like like for instance
I Drive my son's they go to the game mom
yeah I can't believe I kept daddy's soda
but he loves you no he doesn't you know
he loves you yeah he does so go back he
wants the best you need that don't
apologize but find a cushion with the
cushion you can drive even harder
without it you can't point number 20 is
sometimes you are not gonna want to show
up you're just now going to
show up for valid reasons he's in Utah
Salt Lake City Tim Grover orders a pizza
Michael eats it by himself five people
show up and the kind of word hey Mike I
don't have a good feeling about this Tim
is telling this to Mike and Mike eats
the pizza by himself 2:30 in the morning
he calls Tim Tim comes up throwing up
all over the place
doctors all this stuff goes to the game
Tim gave him great advice saying one of
the things I'm telling you right now is
when you're this sick you gotta play the
entire game you can't take a break
because your body you got to play the
whole game Tim just posted something I
think yesterday he said 44 minutes 38
points that's what he posted about that
game and Mike comes scored 38 points 44
minutes they win that game he fully
didn't feel like playing any other all
the right reasons to not play sometimes
you got a play and show up even though
you have valid reasons valid reasons to
not show up
you still got to show up twenty one's a
little painful because I'm a big Scottie
Pippen fan but 21 to me is sometimes
when you quit some things will never
leave you you can lose it's fine
you'll be forgiven you can get knocked
out no problem you'll be forgiven you
can't quit you you can't quit and show
an example of uncoachable 'ti in a
public scene that's gonna stay with you
for a long time when I saw that myself I
said I hope that we're gonna go there
but they did and I know Scottie said if
I had to do it all over again I would
have done the same thing again of course
you wouldn't have because there are
millions of decisions that people go
through that they would have done
differently it just means you don't have
wisdom to make the better decision and
I'm a die-hard Scottie fan I'm a Scottie
found myself I just think sometimes when
everything makes sense for you to quit
and certain decisions are being made
that's unfair coach says Kukoc is gonna
take the last shot instead of you and
Michael's not playing and you're the
number one player name is Pippen and
you're offended by that you can still be
coachable after the game privately bring
it up to your coach not publicly it'll
leave a mark on your reputation for
long time point number 22 is what I call
the flag carrier mentality is Michael
fought for Phil if if if jerry brings
phil back
michael comes back right and he said
that many times michael defended phil
till the very end very very end says a
lot about his character a kobe when I
interviewed Kobe and I said Kobe what do
you see about all the stuff people are
saying about the Knicks and what filled
it as a general manager no he's being
trashed right now the last two or three
years he says listen to me Phil is like
a father figure he's one of the greatest
mentors I ever had in my life and you
see how Mike talks about Phil when you
find a Phil in your life man it's not
easy to find a person like that protect
them keep them maintain the relationship
don't let anybody ever say anything to
the Phil of your life
point number 23 that's the last one and
partly I love this but also don't and
let me explain to why when it ended part
the last dance episode number 10 where
they say Jerry comes out the owner he
says well yeah you know we would have
offered Phil to come back but Phil said
he thinks it's best to step away and
because Phil didn't want to step on the
toes of Jerry Krause the owner said no
Phil you ought to come back is there but
Jerry wants to go a different direction
and he's asking a question about Michael
so Mike what do you think about what
Jerry says for he says since that day
1990 we've never had a conversation
about why didn't we come back why didn't
we come back why don't we do this why
don't we go one more why doesn't
everybody take a one-year contract and
he watches it and sees what is being
said by the way
just so you know he watches it and sees
what's being said and they had to cut it
I don't know if you caught that he was
speechless and I bet he said something
and then he told the camera guy let me
say different thing here to finish up my
thoughts because he was speechless
22 years that's been on his mind never
been brought up and talked about why
don't we come back one more season let's
defend what's ours
somebody's got to dethrone us you can't
go like the sort of guy says are you
happy with the way your career ended
being at the top
everyone's expecting for him to say what
the typical answer which is yes very
happy to me he says no not at all this
is what if we go one more time what if
we went seven what if we went seven can
you imagine this guy's in his mid-50s he
has three kids that are older two sons
and a daughter he's got twins with this
new marriage I believe he's got twins
with his new marriage he's worked a
couple billion dollars he's at dinner
and partied with any name in the world
any name in the world presidents
billionaires models celebrities aced it
doesn't matter and me he's experienced a
royalty at the highest stayed at the
best hotel rooms in the world 50 some
years old and his stomach is still not
full man that says a lot about this guy
his stomach is still not full the
average guy will be like no you know
sometimes you just have to kind of go
and I don't know no he says no the guy
still wants to do that I could add my 7
I mean if a lion could speak you could
not understand him one-of-a-kind
one-of-a-kind type of a player one of a
kind of some two times I cried as a kid
growing up when we came to the States
one and I told this to magic one was
when magic came out and announced HIV
positive cry like a little baby oh my
gosh I was 12 years old I mean I was
devastated when he cannot say that you
know what the second time was when
Michael retired the first time I was I
was not cool with that why because you
know when you love a game and you love
to compete and you have a guy like Kim
that's a once and a general once in a
lifetime we may not see another Michael
me we may not see during my lifetime
Michael is one of a kind when you get a
person like that that changes the game
you have to respect the game and when
this man after all these years after all
these accolades after all the money
after everything he's experienced he
still says no I'm not satisfied that
tells you this is a dude
that even if you would have won a
seventh I guarantee you if you reshoot
and let's just say they would come back
in 1 7 and they would have gone for
eight he would have still said I'm not
satisfied I'm not satisfied because it's
not enough for a strange weird wired
looking guy like this this guy that's
what you call a lion so my final
thoughts on him for point over 23 years
no matter how much you want he wanted
more
so those are my 23 lessons from the last
sense and by the way if you want today's
message in PDF format text Jordan to 3 1
0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2 once again Jordan 2 3 1
0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2 or click on a link below
to go subscribe to my newsletter and
we'll send a PDF to use while I'm by the
way if you haven't seen my interview
with Kobe Bryant click over here we
covered a lot of these topics together
and if you've not seen my sit down when
magic on how he talks about Michael
click on this interview here and if
you're not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care buh bye
you
[Music]